it there a button here now oh
oh What's happen whoa whoa does that
bring people back here it's an emergency
or a body recovery yeah all right jamp
all right Jam I'll give
you oh my god Mar we have a second one
I've got both right now but I think it's
closing off our exits this might be a
bus this might be a we need to get out
cuz there's bad stuff everywhere oh
third coil head just showed up to the
party but he's behind with blob blob
incoming we got we got a countdown right
now blob is incoming towards the main
entrance we got 10 seconds out I think
get out yeah go for
it there's dogs around
here
no
no oh I was right there you should have
closed the door oh the door I forgot to
close the door it look like it killed
you through the wall I got to be honest
that's the second time that I was almost
there and I would have had it but my
mouse moved off of the thing when I got
there so it restarted the start the ship
three
times that
[__] [__] God why did it come for
you guys they both bolted for the ship I
don't know what happened the whole
timeing and it would LED it lorded in
that's uh that's probably Wade's fault
all right our walkies are still here cuz
we died right we all died within 3 ft of
each other so that is true that's good
yeah I was so close I I was right there
God it's so annoying yeah I'm glad you
keep the ship upgrades at least that's
nice yeah we just lose all the stuff
that we got
you want try it yeah I'll try it I'll
give it a go okay I'll bring a shovel
just in case Bob uh if you want to know
there's there's 16 objects of value
outside the ship the approximate value
is
1,484 Sir can you disable a turret near
me all right which one is it there's
many
C7 all right disabling well actually no
I can just tell you when it's orbiting
but I'll disable it in you say when you
want to dis okay don't don't go through
and you're clear you're clear to
go all right I I can't watch both of you
hold on let uh wait there's a turret
around the right corner let me switch
over to uh
Bob all right Bob there's just the one
turret it's looking away right now uh do
you want a window or do you want me to
shut it down no oh it's below you okay
you're
fine all right wait I'm going to shut
off C1 uh you give me the go is C1 to my
right yeah that's to your right okay
once I go that way what direction do I
want to go uh it should be obvious
there's more turrets down the way
there's a rail that'll be straight ahead
past the turret and then there's a door
to the left but there's another turret
over there either way you got to deal
with that other turret it's not going to
be obvious cuz there's steam so I can't
see anything I'm going to need you to
keep disabling that turret while I find
the steam valve yeah you it's going to
be all right cuz you go past the turret
you're going to make a right around the
corner go into the hallway where the
turret is make another right and just go
straight but don't go too far onto the
railway all right I'll try to do what
all that thing you just said okay just
make a right right straight okay disable
it
now
disabled right go right right
straight the Ste okay all right let me
know when to disable it again again
disabled all right Bob how you
doing
Bob H I got bad news about
Bob okay can you disable another turret
in front of
me all right it's
down okay there's three triangles all
around you I feel like I might have
abandoned Bob in his time of need to
focus on
you you got also got like six triangles
all all around
you I've got contact this footsteps
outside the ship but nothing's showing
up on the
radar never mind it's a gigantic Red Dot
the biggest I've ever [__] seen I
don't see any exits around you but
you're obviously drowning in
equipment I'm going to need turret
support okay I'll give it which one you
need okay me okay hold on
F2 it's down uh hold on I found another
item I need
to down
again see1 down
do you need a door
opened you closed
it all right you're
open you're
clean Bob's body is over there I do not
see any red
dots I'll get him on the teleporter be
aware there is a very large thing near
the entrance of the ship I don't don't
hear it anymore but it was gigantic okay
I'm going to drop my Walky and try to
carry a two-handed item back and make
another trip in a minute
yep you're clear so
far what stop stop stop stop stop stop
stop
it's
blocked what was
it oh do we go do we grab grab we won't
see that
that'll didn't work on Bob
teleported oh oh oh I see
[Music]
what what is that do you want to
know you know what no I actually I don't
um time let's goad yeah let's yeah let's
yeah let's what
uh why is it huge why is it so
big because it is
big but it's not a tree thing no yeah I
don't I I don't want to know I don't
actually want to know what it was okay
well that seems rude to me when one of
us died I don't think inuries was hi Bob
oh hey guys how's it going what happened
to you so there was a turret and it was
looking away and I oh I'll just run up
these stairs and it won't see me once
I'm up the stairs it killed me from
directly beneath me through the floor oh
I guess it's a it's like a great floor
right so there's holes in it but I was
like oh it won't be able to see me so I
just went for it and then died
immediately I should have what I fully
break their line of sight it the turrets
are very annoying and there were so many
what I should have done is I should have
memorized the one near you Bob and then
kept typing it while I was watching Wade
cuz he had like a nest of five turrets
that he was swimming through I can't
believe Wade got out of there unscathed
that was ridiculous the one time he came
out of he came out of a door in the da
and were like [__] see yeah yeah as long
as you sprint like they take a moment
they're like as long as you break their
line of sight before that happens or you
get like behind cover you're okay but
like if you're on a staircase there's
not much you can do also Bob I don't
know if you saw what it was is I was
spectating Wade I couldn't see anything
where the dot was on the screen behind
him I don't know if it was up in the air
or what it was it was so big I've never
seen a red dot bigger than that and yet
walk so I bought I bought three do you
want to go in this time Mark do you want
to uh it depends on who wants to I'll
swap out you can all go in at first and
one of us can come back okay is there
any fire exit to this place I think we
have to buy like a couple extension
ladders to get to the fire exit here
it's kind of
tricky okay just going to take a quick
peek around Mark yeah what's up I'm just
peeking
around okay just seeing if the there's
like another back way in or something
the main entrance I'm going to try not
to die immediately also going
in all right I I can't even see a fire
exist so I'm going back to alive I'm
still
alive that's AET oh
good uh be careful there's a turret to
the left uh Roger that on the
turret there's a crawle guy in the main
entrance one of us needs a
shovel
oh God no so uh how you doing Mark I am
geometrically [__] oh what are you
like stuck in a hole on the map or
something yeah yeah I was climbing up
seeing if there was a backway in and uh
fell in a a piece of geometry that is
not letting me
out all right thank you hey you want to
grab a a shovel help me beat something's
ass uh yeah I'll do that that coming
back Bob all right well here I'll go in
first and be your baate ready 3 2 1 here
we go I'm ready where is
it where is it we got a spider web on
the left side what the wait there's n
here there's a turret there's a turret
to the left
careful though actually can't come from
that way there's a turret to the through
this door facing the other way right
here why don't maybe you should go back
and can we wamp the turret is that the
we do I don't think
so
try what the [__] if you hit it it gets
mad shoots 360° which might be useful
wait can you crouch under that did you
crouch under that I could try but I'm
almost dead so if it goes off I'll just
oh you got hit don't don't don't go in
there don't go I got hit a bunch are you
kidding me
oh I did not know
that
ow yeah it doesn't see me if I'm
crouched weird oh it does it does it
does maybe we should just close that
door yeah but now we spider this is just
a dead end over here yeah this is this
is
noo I mean you could jump that I guess
uhoh oh oh oh careful man
careful
man is it worth it going I literally
almost died to that turret I'm just
going to wait here for a second yeah
maybe actually head back to the ship and
watch from the OverWatch oh okay this is
all dead end okay so it's just that axle
to the ship just the axle all right I
think it's just slim pickings here I
think we better cut our losses again
that is a horrible
seed Bob are you all the way over there
on the other side I am not at the ship
I'm stupid ah okay well that's fine
don't worry I'll get there by
midnight well we got some money and I
think enough for the
quota the ship is to your left bobob
careful hey me
he what is it what is it what is it what
is
it give me give me give me give me give
me give me do it doing oh hey man I live
how's it going [__] miracle holy
[__] oh my sweet Jesus wow all right uh
I think we got enough for the quota
we're should be good yeah we're fine
yeah was not a good haul but we got
enough and and man that teleporter what
an investment what an investment J
Christ oh my God fact that you're more
beat up than me and I got shot to hell
well it's it's part of it but uh you
know it could have gone better it could
have gone worse cuz it has I think
anyway I I know we all survived that
like I guess how much better could I
hope for really I don't know it's being
just being greedy at that point
yeah ah the fun toy is that
everything I think
so we didn't have a lot I just had to
pick which things were more valuable so
when Mark was guiding me I kept dropping
everything and like scanning to see what
what was worth the most cuz I had like
eight items I Can Only Hold four of them
I think you did good I'm proud of
you it's fine I'm fine don't worry about
it going to go back on the ship for a
minute I'm going to go ship my pants hey
I me hey that's good Hall you know
actually that's that's barely worse than
our good days that we've had that is
true the bells were worth a lot and the
robot was worth a lot which help
H my new goal is to not almost die only
once on the next
moon a good goal okay that's a great
goal cuz I almost died to the turret and
then I almost got eaten alive so if I
can wiow that down to one near death
experience and
survive a heck of a day you know over
overtime bonus wow wow we we're going to
be living high on the space do hell yeah
just another turret Planet okay so I'll
I'll computer it just in case okay we
know how to get to the the door on this
this the one where the two lights will
be across the way there mark knows about
a fire exit there and there's another
there's like four fire exits in the main
I'll try the rear fire exit
entrance I almost F do that gu a near
death
experience radio check 16 objects wor
$1,400
here that's nice I'm going to grab at
least one of
those okay I'm in it's dark I should
have brought a
flashlight
[Applause]
like door behind you mark there's two
items in
there
Roger got a big
entrance
axle uh Bob there's an item right at the
entrance and then there's
one all right yeah put the Big Bolt and
the axle on the outside over by the fire
exit
cool I don't see anything up here Mark
you go back down and you go out that
direction there should be a
catwalk uh is there a door is there a
door behind you spotted bottles over
here oh I thought you said there there
all right bottles axle and big screw are
outside the fire
exit there's another fire exit right
there Mar there's a through this door
but behind you the opposite direction
there's item out that door to the left
there's a door there should be a door
right there right here left again and
there's an item
there I'm going to bring some stuff back
to the ship sounds good I'll keep eyes
on Bob in the meantime it's
me welcome back thank you I got I'm just
going to go get that actual too but we
got some good decent
stuff keep going straight bob and take
your second right this
one whoa
what uh you guys hear
that Mark you have that giant red circle
on you mark move Mark move oh oh oh my
God oh my God
what is
it what is it what is it what was it did
you see it Mark I did not see it I felt
something pulling at my soul so is it
still the policy of not knowing what it
was it's up to you well I'll leave it a
mystery I guess I've had it try to kill
me multiple times I've only ever seen it
once can I go get the axle or is it noo
no you should you should be able to go
try to get the axle okay I'm going to go
try Bob you need to go the opposite left
go uh yeah
way be careful where you step but the
ship is that way watch out for holes and
quick standand and all that stuff uh to
your right it yeah do what you got to do
to navigate I think I'm on the other
side of a mountain from you so I'm going
have to go
around I think hold go back to the
fire you get back there
okay oh where are you guys
it okay you're clear on the radio or the
radar did anyone get the stuff out of
the main
entrance you not I don't know I I
haven't gone to main entrance so I
haven't seen anything there's a couple
things by the main entrance uh just
sitting outside it all right is it worth
grabbing grab those and get moving it's
getting late all right I'll I'll go grab
them you I've got no items on me so keep
the the uh the teleporter
ready oh my God nope nope nope nope nope
nope
n nope nope that's tree
thums n here I'll go no no there's a dog
there's a dog there's a dog Garden the
only way there dogs are good I don't
mind dogs
what uh no I've got the teleporter ready
all right to your right to your right to
your right oh okay over there all right
oh creature
data um can you switch the radio over to
us real
quick what or the viewport just to
us okay good just just checking I heard
the footsteps we're fine yeah you
they're hey maybe be ready to close the
door though okay I'll be on
door
guys hey hi okay shall
we yeah I guess the dog fine the tree I
hate I can't believe I Sav you you were
beinged MTH the crunch was happening can
we go though can we go we're not okay
okay okay the door does not stay closed
Senor worry pants calm down as we fly
over a series of red dots it's fine
damle I can't believe I saved you wa I
feel like such a hero right now I cannot
either I I was sitting behind that rock
I saw the r me I was like hit the button
hit the button hit the button oh and I
like missed it a bunch before I actually
hit it I was
think this is the time they'll teleport
me right I did the same thing on the
start of the ship when I was going in
and I was
like two more days a sh wow we are
swimming in it her value is already 278
we're already almost there boys oh we're
having a good
run well going to keep being good almost
guaranteed nothing bad will happen I am
not going to die is it my turn on the
computer
um my turn on computer you know what
I'll stay I'll stay in it's kind of my
all right Bridges I I know I ended up on
the computer but that technically you
guys did it the last two rounds so on
walk on check radio check radio check
good check you guys are going in the
opposite
direction that's okay MyWay leads to the
door I'm going for the fire
exit yeah I see what you're doing there
I see Mark I don't know if you can get
back out of fire
exit what do you mean you just have to
yeah you can you just have to go to the
end of the there a giant rock I think
you can go around it but there is a
giant rock n I'll be fine you could
definitely climb out of there I'm
done all right what do you see around me
Bob NADA sorry I'm getting a whole lot
of nothing
here uh Mark if you can make your way
around to the right I saw a couple
triangles oh wait end of the hallway
you're goinging down on the floor right
in front of you got it should be another
one just beyond that
too if you can go up that and to the
right uh there should be some stuff of
up and to the right of where you are
headed to your ring
hole sorry this way that I'm pointed
I've got five items already yeah if you
if there's a door it doesn't look like
that goes anywhere does it is there a
jump there or something oh yeah I can I
can make that I've done that
before did you drop on your items I did
it's a stop sign not very high value and
it's
two-hander that's not two-handed can't
you put that away oh maybe it was maybe
you're
right you are so right two triangles in
this hallway oh you guys are converging
I let you both in the same place hey man
hey what's up can you ask Bob to guide
us back out I think it's this way yeah
Bob can you guide us back
out uh I think we knows the way but yeah
you should think I'm going yeah he says
you're going the right way he says
you're going the I've got multiple loads
outside already
okay all right we're just going to haul
stuff see do I need to come grab or can
you guys
get uh
we're yeah if you come back it would be
helpful all right I'll come
friend yes ah I went the wrong way hello
that's all
good we got so much stuff we can't even
walk damn we are swimming in it all
right Bob I
see walk over
here okay uh well you can leave a
honestly it's not that bad all right Bob
I'm I'm watching
you you're clear are we leaving or
should I go back in I think just we
should leave it's almost 6 or it's past
6 anyway that's three for
me oh is
it oh you're right um I mean we have so
much value but if you want to make a run
I'll keep the the okay yeah keep an eye
on me I'm going to take
another all right Bob you watch him I'll
I'll be on the door all right all right
I'm top I'm on top of the ship so I'm
watching around from up here right as
you left a red dot appeared screaming at
you on the edge of the
screen it's inside though so you're good
there he is all right guys we're so
freaking jacked at this game we really
really good all right we're clear let's
button up we're absolutely beefed right
now what a
hog we still have one more day to lose
bees well we can close this out strong
one final day sure no terrible things
will happen if we go back out and try
and do another one great s ho oh my God
wa that's the most experience I've ever
earned what about those moons that we
have to pay for what are you know the
Primo moons oh yeah we should definitely
risk it all uh we can't afford it yet
but after this haul
the next time we get together we can
definitely afford as long as we don't
screw today up all right well let's not
screw how could we what could go wrong
going back to the one that has the like
Gap in the front like the four fire
exits okay um one of you want to do
computers me to stay do computers uh I
feel like oh yeah no yeah you can do
barely even did computers cuz I you guys
immediately just got everything I'm
going go that I know real
quick I'm going to go to that one okay
cool got some weird fuzzy balls on the
hillside it's
moving excuse me circuit bees Mark
that's a there's a yellow triangle to
your right Mark don't mess with that
right now that that's a way to end
things quickly I think the bees are
collectible but I think they are
difficult need a to collect their
hive that's probably worth all right I'm
inside any
uh go to your left left and then to the
right there's a couple yellow triangles
on this catwalk and then in the room
Beyond this as well you got some
triangles got loot for days all right
sounds good that that was a two-hander I
just passed so I I'll be right
back wait um actually go
back go right and then left at the end
of the hole no yeah sorry left and then
right and there should be something
there
there's another one um if you go with
the direction you're going and turn
right and go
left and then go right and then go right
there should be something there too oh
yeah those are the bottles bottles I
left on the
G you're welcome for leaving back to
this oh Mark go back to the main
entrance
actually yep go right out that door and
then straight across can you go through
that door there yep
to the right in the far corner there's a
there's a something on the ground yes
there is it's the only thing you should
explore the direction you were going to
go next but that's the only thing in
this part I believe it's a dead end to
the rest
of I hear something near me I think
there's a turret um not and a land mine
not too far from
you marker from me
you okay might safe to go right yeah the
way you're facing is safe and you're
back at the main entrance and I don't
see any other
triangles uh hey Mar do you have the
lights off for a
reason I I didn't turn the lights off
are the lights off yeah the lights are
off I've been on the computer grab
Mark's item I got to go all the way back
to my fire exit for the stuff I
missed yeah watch out for those circuit
bees you kind of got to run in between
them but yeah it should be fine wait did
you try the back fire exit or were you
doing the normal fire
exit I did the one like the front of the
ship so if you come back toward main
entrance and do the one on the left
you're fine okay I'll do that
one Mark to your left Red Dot care care
care care oh my God it's a triple it's a
triple there's a triple out oh my God it
might come after me we might want to get
the hell up out of here boys we got on
the map uh okay I'll let you know if it
needs support but I think I'm
okay
yeah
hey you guys are right next to each
other by the Tre yeah don't go to the
right it's it's guarding that fire exit
I'm going to try to go in
again all right back
in got a big bolt down
there yeah I see that back up there is a
yellow triangle I can see I'm going be a
to navigate you
too go oh there's a red dot on the map
moving that's fast that's fast coming
toward I'm out I
bailed I'm just going to come back to
the ship I hear The treeple Stomping
[Music]
around something big just flew over my
head I saw a shadow you see anything on
the map no do I was
watching all right is waade in there
wait is going back to get the stuff he
left outside his fire door okay fire
exit I think he's almost back already
that's the one where the triple was so
he's he's got to
be yesh I could run uh interference on
the treeple if I have nothing and he has
he he's back he's back he's back I don't
want to jinx anything but we're freaking
killing it right now we are crushing it
uh the win I think we're crushing this
this is might be a $1,000 Hall
yeah we can do it yeah yeah this is nuts
best run we've ever had I don't I don't
disagree this soda alone is like an $86
soda I don't know why what kind of soda
did you find Red soda damn are we just
get really good yeah we can definitely
afford to go to one of those other
places next
time man that's so that's how I that's
how I like to I'm A Part
timer
wow hey I was all right whatever this is
going to be such a
hole such a hole good
Lord oh my God I'm so heavy I can't
move oh my God I'm so
heavy what what did you did you I don't
know I'm in encumbered should be a lot
of money come on show us the
money your is invaluable to the
compy oh my God Jesus we're still going
we're in the money we're in the money my
God we're in the
[Music]
money oh Do's open door's open
wait I believe this the last thing last
good God you're so glowy
you can kind of use this as like a
makeshift flashlight inside that's true
not great but it's something
yeah we can't even see what the
individual items are oh this is
amazing it's always scary never not
scary that's what I like to say oh no my
door open when did my door open
uhoh it quit being closed my entire
house has HT our recording session today
hell yeah another $80 apparatus damn
boys that was a
$970
haul hot diggity hot damn all right
let's freaking go I say that's a good
day and I think it's the fitting start
of a new chap is that a
[Music]
gun